what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series uh today I am going to
be reacting to the current crisis of
masculinity but before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that we are
going to be notified of my daily videos
let's get started all right what do we
got so Jordan oh is Jordan Peterson's
lead this new series Dragons monsters
men the first one that we're doing
together this series is focused daily
wire is so legit look at them see that
stage how men can be men why do you
think there is such a crisis of
masculinity in the first place and why
are there so many people out there who
are angry at you for even talking to men
well I think it's I think you could
think about it as I would say because
there's evil feminists that just hate
men sequence in some sense of the lack
of a concept of original sin oddly
enough I mean people bear an existential
burden you know it's an intrinsic part
of life to
I suppose
to feel guilty in relationship to Nature
and to feel guilty in relationship to
culture you know it's difficult for us
to live in harmony with the natural
world and for the natural world to live
in harmony with us by the way and none
of us are all we could be on the social
front and one of the consequences and so
we we have that sense intrinsically you
know that there's a lack in us that
needs to be redressed and unfortunately
that can be weaponized and has been and
what I see happening to young men in
particular boys as well not just young
men and maybe even
you know maybe starting at the age of
toddlers is that we have this sense in
the world that human beings live in
antagonism to Nature and that we're
actually a malevolent force and that our
social structures which are clearly
capable of the commission of atrocity
are fundamentally oppressive patriarchal
in their nature and so then if you're a
I actually think it's the opposite I
don't think it's I don't think we live
in a patriarchy at all I think we live
it's weird I think we live in a
matriarchy and I know I know you guys
are going to think this is crazy and
maybe matriarchy isn't in the right word
so it might not be a matriarchy but I do
think women hold most of the power in
society now why do I think this right
because again men are a very like they
hold most of the positions of power
they're at the top of most organizations
you would think it would be the opposite
but the guys at the top of those
organizations in order to sell product
have to Pander to who women because we
make 70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decision so the messaging that we're
going to get and get from advert
advertisers is for women in the media
for women because again we're trying to
sell except on this channel right
um and then on top of that the
politicians have to Pander to women
because we're the biggest Swing Vote so
and we're also the most easily
manipulated by Propaganda and I was
talking about this earlier I think that
men
um you guys weren't here but I was
talking about this with my producer
earlier I think men have this natural
like gift of logic from God and I think
women have a natural gift of like
emotion from God but the issue is that I
think that like men in power
oftentimes use like women's ability to
be manipulated in order to control
societies I have a weird thought process
on this but that's why I genuinely think
that women in general hold more power
than men in general like the average
woman holds more power than the average
guy male in a society with that ethos
you're the motive force that drives you
into the world to live is associated
with rapaciousness and despoilation on
the natural front and then oppression
and atrocity on the social front it's
like well then if you're the least bit
conscientious because this sort of
accusation hurts conscientious young men
the most then the best you can do is
well let's say castrate yourself how
would that be and that would be real
comical except that it's also happening
so I guess that's why that's why I think
there's a crisis yeah because they shame
men for being met whenever it's so
interesting because once you see this
you can't unsee it the the female way of
like doing things is always looked at as
good so men fighting out their problems
like punching each other that sort of
thing bad talking out their problems
good a guy of opening up and letting out
his emotions good showing aggression bad
and it's just interesting like again
that's why I think that women hold more
power are in society because we have the
most influence over the next Generation
because the majority of teachers are
women the majority of psychologists are
women who has more influence than a
teacher and psychologist they're saying
the average parent spends like 30
minutes a day with their kid who is
going to have more influence over your
kid a teacher that spends eight hours a
day with your kid or you and the issue
is a lot of these teachers are like
feminists and they promote this like
Marxist feminist ideology so again
average woman way more power than the
average man man just my opinion and it
there's something serious at the root of
it right because we do have to take the
fact of our the potential damage we can
do to the natural world and the social
world we have to take that seriously but
the the proper consequence of taking
that seriously is not to commit Harry
Kerry let's say in a fit of moral
anxiety and take yourself completely out
of the game but that's the insistence
now and it's really and I see that
psychoanalytically you know I see that
as a manifestation at a symbolic level
of something like well symbolically
that's associated with the devouring
mother right it's it's an overweening
and destructive false compassion that
has this devouring quality and right the
devouring mother that's interesting I
need to think about that more yeah and
that's basically where we're at so so
you know it's one of the things that's
striking about the sort of hatred that
you've gotten from so many is that you
you've literally I miss Ben Shapiro
dunking on college kids Ben please I
know you have this like classy brand now
but can you please please come on one of
my shows I will give you some college
women to dunk on I promise you please I
am begging you the fans miss it did you
watch those King are you Ben Shapiro fan
like back in the day when he would just
go to those woke liberal college
campuses
and like these these like you know 18
year old girls would come in and say I
think that a man is a woman and a woman
is a man
we need to we're going to react to that
today because I miss it asked why you're
even bothering to speak to men I mean
there is this Christ masculinity right
there is this idea that every form of
masculine and masculinity is toxic and
you've spent your life trying to talk to
men and say no no you can channel that
masculinity in not only a good way but a
necessary and productive and and useful
way well you cannot build societies
without masculinity because when you
think about it every society needs
protection and that's a masculine trait
I saw um like it's interesting when
there's like something bad happening
it's so interesting because I think
women like naturally run away from it
where men like run into it and that's a
masculine trait like I saw this um kid
where the bus driver was like overweight
and I don't know maybe drugs or
something but the bus driver passed out
and the freaking kid runs forward and
grabs the bus and like drives it to
safety and I was like that's masculinity
in its finest it's like men running
towards danger like we literally cannot
function as a society without masculine
and it just doesn't work